bernard drainville député de marie
victorin ans un ancien ministre
responsable du projet la loi sur la
charte des valeurs c'est peut-être
l'image avait vu le plus souvent dans
les six derniers mois dans la sphère
politique au québec
présentation de ce projet de charles
d'hallendre avait le bon soir bonsoir
fabrice est ce qu'on peut clarifier si
c'est possible si c'est possible je
pensais pas ces histoires d'avis
juridiques
oui beaucoup de gens bernard drainville
se sont sentis floués des gens qui
appuyaient la charge avait lui comme moi
beaucoup chroniqueur des intellectuels
des gens qui ont dit mais bon dieu
est-ce qu'ils ont pris ce travail au
sérieux
oui dans la mesure où au ministère de la
justice on dit il n'ya pas eu de
commande un avis juridique sur le projet
de loi dans son entièreté
soit vous admettez ça oui mais il ya eu
des avis juridiques sur les parties
essentielles les parties des parties
importantes de la charte qui par
ailleurs moi j'avais consulté pendant
tout l'été
pas loin de 10 juristes dont certains
d'éminents juristes par exemple en
claire l'heureux dubé
moi j'ai monsieur asec madame
l'heureux-dubé là je lui ai demandé
madame l'heureux dubé à votre avis le
projet ce qu'il est constitutionnel
je lui avais présenté le projet et là il
m'a fait la démonstration une
démonstration juridique un argumentaire
juridique très rigoureux et on avait la
vie de monsieur brun bref l'addition de
tous ces avis de toutes ces opinions de
toutes ces analyses nous donnait
l'argumentaire juridique pour nous
permettre de dire ce projet il est
constitutionnelle maintenant les gens se
sont sentis floués pourquoi parce que la
semaine passée la menace de la justice
dit avait pas d'avis juridiques alors
dans les jours qui ont suivi
effectivement tous des commentateurs qui
avait appuyé la charte qui ont dit ça
n'a pas de bon sens comment s'assurer
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'avis juridiques
le problème c'est qu'ils en avaient des
avis juridiques y avait et le la
ministre changé d'idée là les gens la
maison se disent à vue
riddick est ce qu il n'y avait pas et je
vous demande pourquoi vous n'avez pas
demandé un avis juridique en bonne et
due forme sur l'entièreté sur l'ensemble
de ce projet de loi ce que l'on fait à
québec pour à peu près tous les projets
de loin ce c'est sûr c'est discutable
mais ce que je vous dis c'est que vous
me dites pourquoi vous aviez pas un avis
juridique sur l'ensemble moi je vous dis
j'avais des avis juridiques et des
opinions juridiques et des analyses
juridiques sur l'ensemble moi je suis
allé chercher dans le fond
en quelques pages en effet plus que
nécessaire non seulement j'avais des
avis juridiques au ministère de justice
j'avais des avis externe je suis allé
chercher la plus large panoplie possible
le plus large éventail possible de
conseil david analyse parce que si on
vous posant la question devait rendre à
vue c'est que pendant ce avant la
campagne pendant le débat sur l'achat
vous disiez ou issati la route ce projet
là aussi niveau même constitutionnel on
a des avis juridiques
oui or vous comprenez la surprise on en
est jean région d exane meetic j'aurais
pu demander un avis complet écrit je
trouve que vous êtes je pose sur parler
des gens la maison la peau sur l'eau que
t d'or tu rencontres l'ancien juge de la
cour suprême tu rencontres des juristes
éminents tu as un avis externe sur des
avis à l'internaute un équipe de
juristes un moment donné il
qu'est-ce que ça prendrait de plus le
qu'est ce que ça aurait pris de plus
pour asseoir les fondements juridiques
du projet moi je vous dis parce qu'à un
moment donné ils leur mettez deux
avocats dans une dans une pièce le ils
vont sortir de la pièce avec trois
opinions juridiques je sais que c'est un
fait ça c'est un fait et ce que je vous
dis non mais c'est un fait que je peux
pas attendre l'unanimité des juristes
avant de trancher
la job des élus loges avant de trancher
vous auriez pu choisir de demander un
avis en bonne et due forme écrit complet
ficelé non mais vous auriez pu et sport
oui j'aurais pu ré bien que vous me
lisez vos avis partiaux sur l'article 5
justement sur nous je vous le dirai pas
je vous dirai pas ce que les avis
juridiques disait parce que c'est
précisément la raison pour laquelle je
ne suis pas sorti ces derniers jours
parce que je trouve irresponsable que
les libéraux se soit engagé à dévoiler
avis juridique
parce que ça se fait jamais ou presque
jamais ça et je trouve irresponsable que
la nouvelle ministre la justice et
discuter publiquement des avis
juridiques la semaine dernière mais ce
que je peux vous dire qu'on attende un
peu je réponds à votre question ce que
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que sur
les aspects essentiels du projet de loi
notamment la question de l'interdiction
des signes religieux
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que les
avis que nous avons reçues couvrait ses
aspects devraient donner un aspect là
les avis que vous avez reçus sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux
l'article 5 pourquoi vous ne demandez
pas spécifiquement au gouvernement
libéral actuellement de les libérer
comme ça vous diriez arabe
le voici la vie j'en avais ben voyons
donc
non pourquoi parce que si tu fais pas ça
les avis juridiques là si tu commences à
des voix les avis juridiques là puis tu
le fais pour la charte
il va arriver quoi dans les autres
projets de loi les groupes de pression
vont pouvoir sortir les les citoyens
vont pouvoir dire à bien vous l'avez
fait pour tel projet de loin rendez le
public pour tel autre projet de loi puis
pour les gens qui nous écoutent à la
maison pourquoi c'est important de pas
le faire c'est parce que si jamais la
loi contesté puis de rendu public les
avis juridiques
la personne qui conteste la loi va
pouvoir prendre tes propres avis
juridiques et les retourner contre toi
ils vont pouvoir attaquer pas loin avec
les mêmes avec les conseils que tu
heureux si tu de tes propres avocats
alors en conclusion en conclusion bien
tendre avait là dessus vous dites je dis
ce qui fait croire aux dés fois écrit
des fois pas inscrit
j'avais tout ce qu'il fallait pour
prendre une décision et la job des nuls
patrice ces deux tranchées et on a
tranché à la lumière d'une race d'un
vaste éventail d'avis juridiques l'autre
sujet sur la charte et je me souviens je
vous ai posé la question trois ou quatre
fois sur ce plateau là je vous ai
demandé pourquoi vous ne vous mettez pas
un peu d'eau dans votre vin pour vous
entendre avec la cac
de sorte que nous aurions peut-être au
québec une charte des valeurs - moins
agressive que ce que vous auriez
souhaité mais en tout cas il y aurait eu
un consensus là il faut être franc avec
les gens qui nous écoutent là on aurait
pu avoir une charte ci avait pas eu
d'élection si le processus parlementaire
qu'on devait suivre avait été si s'était
poursuivie si la la commission
parlementaire avait terminé ses travaux
on aurait pu effectivement ça soit avec
avec la calorie moi je pense
bien ah non non non mais non sur une
consultation générale la consultation
générale dit tous ceux et celles qui
dépose le mémoire en droit de se faire
entendre mais faut pas arriver puis dire
ben je vais changer les règles j'en
entends juste 50 pour moi pour me donner
le temps de m'asseoir avec la carte là
où vous avez par contre raison avec le
recul je pose des questions mais c'est
bien de payer pour sûr un bon mois
depuis l'élection j'ai discuté avec
beaucoup de gens que j'essaye de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et il ya
des citoyens qui me disent on n'avait
pas l'impression que tu étais prête à
tendre avec laquelle puis moi
sincèrement j'étais prêt m'entendre avec
la cac
à la fin du processus alors viré parce
qu'il aurait je pense qu'il a voulu
avait dit après la défaite non mais je
pendant le processus je disais écoutez
j'ai fait à city crom là où j'ai dit
finissons le travail de la commission
puis après on voit s'asseoir avec la caq
puis on va s'entendre
ça je les dis je les dis je le redis
mais ce que je disais c'est qu'il
fallait terminer le processus parce que
mon objectif c'était sincèrement le
faire adopter
est-ce que j'aurais dû envoyer un signal
plus fort sur ma volonté de m'entendre
sur le fait que je croyais sincèrement
que je pouvait m'entendre probablement
avec le recul je pense que je mets ça
n'aurait rien changé au processus qui
fait les suivre comment vous avez depuis
le 7 avril digérer cette défaite
électorale pour votre parti est ce que
vous avez déjà des premières leçons est
ce que vous serez candidat j'ai
tellement paulette des jeux pohlad
parce que avant décidé d'être candidat
il faut toujours bien que tu comprennes
ce qui s'est passé puis moi sincèrement
j'entends les explications puis à des
explications je pense que ça impose un
peu d'elle même je ne vous livrerez pas
ce soir parce que sincèrement ça fait
partie d'une réflexion plus large mais
je vous dirais je suis encore en train
de me demander qu'est-ce qui sait qu'est
ce qui s'est passé il additionne et vous
êtes encore sony va sonner je l'était au
début le ch - du moins ce n'est que dans
une profonde réflexion puis je suis
vraiment je me creuse les méninges puis
je creuse en moi même aussi je vous
dirais un peu les g7 comprend que
j'essaie de trouver puis je pense qu'une
des façons d'y arriver c'est de d'écouté
pour ceux qui m'avaient pas entendu
beaucoup parler depuis l'élection
je pose beaucoup de questions
puis j'écoute les réponses puis j'essaie
de faire une tête j'essaye de me faire
une synthèse c'est comme ça notamment
que je suis arrivé à la conclusion que
sur l'idée d'en venir à une entente avec
la cac
peut-être que le message était pas
suffisamment clair puis ma volonté
d'ouverture était pas suffisamment
manifeste alors là dessus je vous dirais
j'ai commencé à tirer quelques
conclusions
mais sur l'ensemble s'est pas fait
encore l'avenir et l'ont nourri leur
dirai oui absolument
et le pire n'arrive pas toujours à l'or
noir eu le temps de se reparler bernard
is back
le pire n'a lui merci l'an passé la nuit
sur notre plateau